today I want to talk about stretching
your comfort zone I put out a message on
my newsletter list to say hey I'm coming
to Vancouver for this event with dal and
Soho and I want to meet whoever's here
let's go out and see the city and my
friend Gabriel here
a new friend Gabriel we met at the hotel
he took me out to an awesome local pub
to have some food and I said hey we
never do a video and I put him here on
this street corner and we just did a
one-minute Monday and he was nervous
were you nervous we took we took it we
took a number it takes ing few girls
walking by - man that's why he's never
just checking out the cute girls anyway
but Gabriel today
stretched his comfort zone okay he took
an opportunity to meet somebody to talk
about his business and then when I
pitched the middie of making a video
he's all over it he's never done it
before but he stretched he can do it
again better now and if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur it's gonna
come from doing things that make you
feel a little bit uncomfortable and
every time you do it you feel a little
bit more comfortable next time and the
next time and the next time if you keep
doing the same thing over and over again
you're gonna get the same results you
got to stretch your comfort zone but
Gabriel did today give us give us your
website again tomorrow so go check it
out and every week I shared my best
information to help you fuel your
business forward
in my newsletter check it out below hi
I'm Jason j-rock Fonseca Rosalyn calm
and I want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and it's the only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period